Welcome, everybody.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Yeah, you're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is the holiday season.
Isn't it a great time
to be here in New York City?
Doesn't it feel good?
But I just saw that the police
just warned tourists
to be on the lookout
for pickpockets.
And to everyone in the audience
who just checked your pockets,
it's too late now.
You can never be too safe.
That's why this time of year,
instead of a wallet,
I keep all my money in crypto.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Pickpockets are everywhere.
'Cause nothing ruins a week
of $200 Broadway tickets
and $12 pretzels
like getting ripped off.
You know what I'm saying?
Hey, here's some good news
for the holidays.
After more than a year
of record inflation,
it looks like prices
are finally starting to go down.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. So...
So, take that, annoying people
who finished all their
Christmas shopping in November.
Ha ha!
We win!
Some political news.
Tomorrow is
the Georgia Senate runoff
between Herschel Walker
and Senator Raphael Warnock.
Warnock's supporters said
that they're voting for him
because of his policies,
while Walker's supporters say
they're voting for him
because it's funny.
[ Laughter ]
More than 1.8 million Georgia
residents have already voted,
and that's just
Herschel Walker's children.
[ Audience oohs ]
Right now --
[ Applause ]
-Whoa!
-Right now,
Warnock is leading Walker
in the polls by about 4 points.
Yeah, only 4 points.
That explains
Warnock's slogan...
It's like -- It's only 4 points.
Tomorrow is the big runoff
between Herschel Walker
and Raphael Warnock.
And I must say,
it's nice to see two candidates
set aside their personal attacks
and focus on real issues
in their campaign.
Check out this ad
for Herschel Walker.
-Herschel Walker
has always let Georgians know
where he stands
on the important issues
like taxes, jobs...
and vampires.
-[ Hissing ]
-I don't know if you know.
Vampires are some cool people,
are they not?
But I'm-a tell you something
today I found out.
A werewolf can kill a vampire.
Do you know that?
-Where does Raphael Warnock
stand on vampires?
He's never told us.
But Herschel Walker has.
-Because, you know,
gotta have a stake
and gotta have a thing
that kill 'em in the heart.
And you got a necklace of
garlic, 'cause that work.
I don't know what it does,
but it work.
Gotta have a cross 'cause
it burns. I know that works.
-So I don't want to be
a vampire anymore.
I want to be a werewolf.
[ Wolf howls ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, everyone's
talking about this.
Over the weekend,
former President Trump
called for the 2020 election
to be overturned
by terminating the Constitution.
[ Audience oohs ]
And Trump can actually do it
because he has the real
Constitution hanging in
the bathroom at Mar-a-Lago.
[ Laughter ]
So he could...
Trump wants to terminate
the Constitution.
Then a staffer held a brick
to his ear like,
"Yeah, working on it
right now, sir. Yeah."
Well, listen to this.
I read that compared
to past presidents,
books about President Biden
aren't selling many copies.
Yeah, you can tell that Biden
books aren't that exciting.
I mean, just look
at the blurbs on the back.
For instance, this critic from
"The New York Times" wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up,
"The Washington Post" wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then "USA Today" wrote...
-Wow!
-These are the blurbs
on the back of --
on the back of the book
that real humans wrote. Wow.
-Yeah. Yeah.
"Time" Magazine wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally,
the "Chicago Tribune" wrote...
I mean, why would you put that
on the back of the --
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Some entertainment news.
A new episode of "White Lotus"
dropped last night,
and it was a real doozy.
-Oh, no. No spoilers.
I haven't seen it yet.
-Oh, I wasn't
gonna spoil anything.
I was just saying
it was a good episode. I --
-I don't care.
I might be able
to extrapolate information
from what you say.
-I don't see
how that's possible.
-Just don't. Okay?
-Alright. Fine.
What else can we talk about?
Everyone's talking
about the show "Wednesday" --
-Ah, wah-wah-wah! No spoilers.
-I was just gonna say the dance
scene is getting a lot of buzz.
-Great, Jimmy. Now I know
there's a dance scene.
-Everyone knows
It's huge on TikTok.
-Great!
Now I know it's huge on TikTok!
-Alright. Fine. What else
is there to talk about?
"Yellowstone" is big right now.
-Ahh-- I haven't seen it.
-"Violent Night"
is getting good reviews.
-Haven't seen it.
-The trailer for "Cocaine Bear."
-♪ La dee da dee da da da ♪
-The "Survivor" finale is --
-♪ Loo loo loo loo,
loo loo loo loo loo ♪
-Alright. Fine. Fine. We'll talk
about the news instead.
Alright? Everyone knows the U.S.
lost to the Netherlands.
-In what?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-President Joe Biden --
-He won the election?
[ Laughter ]
-Donald Trump --
-He won the election?!
-Christmas is almost here.
-It is?
-Alright. That's enough.
You're behind on everything.
What have you been doing
this whole time?
-Wordle. I'm actually doing
today's puzzle right now.
-Well, get a load of this.
It's actually woken.
W-O-K-E-N.
"Woken" is the word today.
-I swear to God.
Mother [bleep]!
-Hey, hey, hey! Hey, hey!
Come on, man! Whoa! Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sorry!
Unbelievable. Sorry!
-Steve: Wow.
-Guys, get this.
Following a pause
during the pandemic,
the Catholic Church
has reintroduced handshakes
during mass.
-[ Applause ]
-[ Woman exclaims ]
-Really?
-Wow.
-Peace be with you. Wow.
-Yep, shaking hands at church,
or as Mike Pence calls it,
"going all the way."
[ Laughter ]
Hey. Did you guys see this?
Everyone's been using
this new A.I. app
that takes your selfies
and turns them
into beautiful portraits.
I did mine earlier today.
Look at -- Look at mine.
They made me look like a...
1930s Hollywood star.
-Oh.
-Quest, did you try it?
-Yeah, I did.
Check it out, man.
-Ooh.
-See?
That's what I look like
as an impressionist painting.
-Yeah, I love that.
Higgins, did you try it?
-Yeah. Take a look.
-Hey! God!
What filter is that?!
-Filter? That was Saturday.
-Oh, my God!
Moving on. [ Clears throat ]
Hey, guys, I heard about a
tattoo removal studio in London
that's lasering off
Kanye West tattoos for free.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's great. You just walk in
and say, "Make my Ye a nay."
[ Applause ]
Finally, we have
exactly 10 shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Ten days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an exquisite Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to Christmas
Cabinet.
Now, since there are
10 shows left,
let's open door number 10.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ready for this?
Ooh! [ Laughs ]
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is --
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Alright.
Now let's see who's gonna
go home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
Who wants this sweater?!
It's a good one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
216!
Come on! Come on!
♪♪
Come on! How you doing?
Nice to see you. How are you?
Why don't you stand over there?
Here you go.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Leah. I'm from Germany.
-Yeah! Leah from Germany!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. We love Germany.
Thanks for coming to the show.
I appreciate this.
It gets cold in Germany, right?
-It does.
-Yeah.
Do you have anything like this?
-Not yet.
-Yeah.
Would you like to try it on?
-Absolutely.
-Yeah. Here. Go for it.
This is gonna be fun.
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You're -- It's very --
Oh, yeah!
This is good.
Wow!
Stunning! Stunning!
Gorgeous!
That's what I'm talking about.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I appreciate this.
Let's give our winner a round
of applause. Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Selena Gomez, everybody!
Come on back!
♪♪